[Music]
is there a role a type of role that
you've wanted to play that they have not
offered you yet I suppose anything
anything remotely sexy that wouldn't
work
I hit a villain I'd like a villain a
villain in a sort of superhero just an
evil and evil guy in a superhero film
that'll be funny you'd like to be like
an evil supervillain yeah I'll be good
what would your power be you think oh I
don't know I look for it thrilled you
know that joy forever can't I just I'd
be annoying I'm really annoyed be just
not super it you'd be a super annoying
yeah anyone that came to bat mama go
even go to fight you you'd be so
annoying exist but what is that over and
over again you're coming with me you
can't
[Laughter]
incredibly annoying annoying you're
incredibly annoying
you're awfully annoying yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I've been on this earth for a while but
he's good to see me kept up the high
standard is anyone tuning in right now
since to grow
you know I do know how to defeat you
well we've talked about this before
you're very ticklish I am that would be
the way that would be the way to defeat
very ticklish that is my kryptonite yeah
oh great an oilman you know shut up
Batman
well I'm there if you know that movie I
am there Oh